- [Narrator] Bitcoin and Ethereum.
So, you know the top
two players in crypto,
but what about the Cardano
Network's coin Ada.
Ada is an altcoin, meaning
it's an alternative
to Bitcoin and is named after
the 19th century
mathematician, Ada Lovelace,
who is considered the
first computer programmer.
Late this summer, of surge in interest
in Ada pushed the cryptocurrency
to the third largest,
behind Bitcoin and ether,
Ethereum's currency.
During the rise, Ada reached
a market capitalization
of more than $90 billion and
rose to a high of more than $3.
That's nearly a 2500% increase in price
on a year over year basis.
- That's primarily driven
by retail investors.
And I think a lot of the ones
that I've talked to are saying,
"I want to kind of find the next Bitcoin.
So maybe that's Cardona's Ada token."
- [Narrator] Given the
crypto market's volatility,
the third largest changes often,
but with nearly 6,000 cryptocurrencies
in existence this year,
why is Cardona's Ada
one of the few breaking through?
We'll explain.
Cardano describes itself as a
third generation blockchain platform.
You can think about the
blockchain generations,
similar to the evolution
of the cell phone.
Bitcoin, the first generation
is like the flip phone.
It was revolutionary in its creation,
but only does basic things.
The second generation Ethereum 1.0,
that's like your first few smartphones.
It offers apps, but is
kind of slow to load.
The third generation
Cardano and Ethereum 2.0,
want to be more like phones today,
where speed and usability are crucial.
The key difference between
the first generation and the third
has to do with how the network works.
Bitcoin runs on something called
a proof of work mechanism,
which runs something like this,
miners, not those ones,
but people who set up computers,
allow the system to work,
their computers simultaneously race
to guess a complex sequence of numbers
in order to validate a
block of transactions.
The miner whose computer
wins is awarded Bitcoin
and records the validated transaction
on the blockchain ledger.
A fancy word that essentially
means the online record book.
But aspect when prices rise,
so do the barriers to enter for miners.
- [Caitlin McCabe] So we're seeing
companies fully dedicated to mining.
We're seeing miners taking
over warehouses and factories
to set up mining facilities.
- [Narrator] While secure,
this system requires
huge amounts of processing power,
simply because it requires all
mining computers to
work on the same puzzle.
And it rewards those with
more computing power.
Just how much power?
In a year, the Bitcoin
network uses about the same
amount of electricity as Washington State.
- We've seen proof of work
increasingly come under scrutiny
because of the energy
intensity that it uses.
- [Narrator] This is one
of the biggest challenges
of the first generation of crypto,
and a main reason why
Cardano is breaking through.
Cardano uses a different
system called proof of stake.
A system also adopted by
Ethereum second model,
Ethereum 2.0, which is expected
to be fully rolled out in the future.
- The proof of stake model is, I think,
a very exciting prospect for people
who are in the space because
it uses an entirely different system
in order to verify
transactions on the blockchain.
- [Narrator] In Cardona's
proof of stake model,
Ada owners use their own holdings
to help validate transactions.
This is called staking or delegating.
Think of a stake as a commitment to keep
the Cardona network operating and secure.
To earn Ada users join a stake pool,
either one they've made or another user's.
Not every user in the stake pool
is responsible for verifying transactions.
Instead one user, a pool operator,
does the work on behalf of the group
cutting down on computer activity.
So in short, in first-generation crypto,
every computer races to
solve one math puzzle.
In third generation,
only the state pool
operator does the work.
But the proof of stake system,
isn't the only factor that
helped Cardona breakthrough.
Cardano recently introduced something
called smart contracts to its system,
with an upgrade it calls Alonzo.
Smart contracts are seen as game changers
because they allow the blockchain
to host other operations.
Again, think of a smartphone.
It's similar to the idea of an app store,
except with a blockchain,
these apps are called dApps
or decentralized apps,
and there is no company
like Apple or Google
in between the user and the application.
Instead, the smart contract
has programmed code
to facilitate agreements and transactions
between the user and the dApp.
Users hope Cardano's
adoption will allow it
to better compete with
the Ethereum network,
Where about 80% of dApps are built.
But all that traffic has created issues.
- The reason that Ethereum has
faced some scrutiny this year
is just because there've been,
there's been so much
activity on the network
that there's been more congestion
and higher transaction fees
in order to try to
transact on the network.
So the idea for Cardano is to take
the Ethereum model and
make it more scalable.
- [Narrator] While Cardano's promises
may sound great in theory,
they've yet to undergo the
most important test, time.
- We'll have to wait and see, you know,
how successful people are
able to use the platform
in order to, you know, build
decentralized applications
and create non fungible tokens.
- [Narrator] The introduction
of smart contracts
is stage three in a five part plan,
according to the platform's roadmap.
Still to come are upgrades on
scalability and governance.
- Investors have to keep in mind,
this is not going to
be a steady investment.
But I think people who like
to trade in mid-volatility,
that's one of the draws.
- [Narrator] The blockchain
engineering company
behind Cardona, IOHK,
warned that expectations
need to be managed with this upgrade.
So how smart contracts will
impact Cardona in the long run?
Time will have to tell.